WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
WHAT A WEIRD DAY IT WAS IN
WASHINGTON.
HARD AS IT MAY BE TO BELIEVE,
TWO WEEKS AFTER THE RELEASE OF
THE MUELLER REPORT.
BUT ON CAPITOL HILL TONIGHT THEY
ARE STILL YELLING ABOUT RUSSIA!
IT'S AS IF THE MOST EXHAUSTIVE
FEDERAL INVESTIGATION IN A
GENERATION NEVER EVEN HAPPENED.
IT'S AS IF THE RUSSIA COLLUSION
STORY WAS COMPLETELY REAL AND
NOT A LUDICROUS HOAX PUBLISHED
BY RUTHLESS PARTISANS.
IT'S IS A FACTS NO LONGER MATTER
AT ALL, ONLY EMOTION AND
AMBITION AND THE OVERRIDING WILL
TO POWER.
THESE APPARENTLY ARE THE NEW
RULES IN WASHINGTON.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM
BARR LEARNED OF THEM TODAY AS HE
WAS SUMMONED BEFORE THE
CONGRESS.
ANGRY DEMOCRATS INTERROGATED HIM
BUT THE LETTER HE WROTE IN MARCH
SUMMARIZING THE MUELLER REPORT.
YOU MIGHT WONDER WHY ANYONE
WOULD CARE ABOUT THAT LETTER,
THE ENTIRE MUELLER REPORT WAS
SUBSEQUENTLY RELEASED RIGHT
AFTER THE LETTER.
THAT REPORT IS NOW AVAILABLE
ONLINE.
ANYONE CAN READ IT, YOU CAN READ
IT IF YOU WANT AND THEN DRAW
YOUR OWN INDEPENDENT CONCLUSIONS
ABOUT WHAT IT SAYS.
YOU DON'T NEED BOB BARR'S HELP,
HIS SUMMARY IS IRRELEVANT.
NOW OUR PARTISANS ON CABLE TV
ARE PRETENDING OTHERWISE.
LET'S BE VERY CLEAR, WHAT THEY
ARE GIVING YOU HIS OPINION.
IT'S NOT FACT AND THEY SHOULD BE
HONEST ABOUT THAT.
TELL BARR LETTER MEANS NOTHING.
AGAIN, THAT IS FACT, NOT
OPINION.
SO WHAT WAS THE POINT OF TODAY'S
HEARINGS?
WHILE PART OF THE POINT WAS TO
ALLOW PEOPLE LIKE ME LIKE MAZIE
HIRONO TO PERFORM FOR THE
CAMERAS.
A FEW YEARS AGO, VIRTUALLY NO
ONE OUTSIDE OF HAWAII HAD HEARD
OF HER.
SHE WAS CONSIDERED FORGETTABLE
EVEN BY STANDARDS OF THE U.S.
SENATE.
NOW SHE'S A CELEBRITY ON CNN.
TECHNICALLY SHE REMAINS
UNIMPRESSIVE, SHE'S NEVER
WRITTEN A SINGLE BILL THAT YOU
HAVE HEARD OF.
BUT WHEN THE CAMERAS ROLLING,
SHE WILL REPEAT LITERALLY
ANYTHING OR STAFF PUTS ON A CARD
AND ENHANCE HER NO MATTER HOW
EXTREME AND STUPID IT MIGHT BE.
HERE SHE WAS TODAY.
>> MR. BARR, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
KNOW YOU ARE NO DIFFERENT THAN
RUDY GIULIANI, KELLYANNE CONWAY
OR ANY OF THE OTHER PEOPLE WHO
SACRIFICED THEIR ONCE DECENT
REPUTATION FOR THE LIAR WHO SITS
IN THE OVAL OFFICE.
HE ONCE TURNED DOWN A JOB OFFER
FROM DONALD TRUMP'S CONCERNS
WERE LEGITIMATE.
YOU DIDN'T KNOW BOB MUELLER
SUPPORTED YOUR CONCLUSIONS BUT
YOU KNEW THAT YOU LIED TO.
I WASN'T SURPRISED.
YOU DID EXACTLY WHAT I THOUGHT
YOU WOULD DO WHICH IS WHY I
VOTED AGAINST YOUR CONFIRMATION.
BUT NOW WE KNOW MORE ABOUT YOUR
DEEP INVOLVEMENT AND TRYING TO
COVER UP FOR DONALD TRUMP.
BEING THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
THE UNITED STATES IS SACRED
TRUST.
YOU HAVE BETRAYED THAT TRUST AND
AMERICA DESERVES BETTER.
YOU SHOULD RESIGN.
>> Tucker: READING IT RIGHT
OFF THE CARD.
HAND HER THE CARD, THERE YOU GO.
SHE WILL READ IT.
DEEP INVOLVEMENT IN A COVER-UP.
BILL OUR ROLE READ THE LETTER ON
MARCH 24TH.
THAT MEANS THAT FOR THREE AND A
HALF LONG WEEKS AMERICA WAS
UNDER THE FALSE IMPRESSION THAT
DONALD TRUMP WAS NOT A RUSSIAN
AGENT.
TWO CORY BOOKER OF NEW JERSEY
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A SOPHISTICATED
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN RUN BY,
YOU GUESSED IT.
RUSSIAN AGENTS.
>> WE HAVE HERE DOCUMENTED A
LEVEL OF CLO ORDINATION WITH A
FOREIGN ADVERSARY SHARING
POLLING DATA.
AND, YOUR CONDUCT SEEMS TO BE
TRYING TO NORMALIZE THAT
BEHAVIOR WHICH IS WHY I THINK
YOU ARE IN SUCH A SERIOUS MOMENT
THAT IS ERODING THE CULTURES OF
THIS DEMOCRACY.
SO LET'S GET INTO SOME OF THIS
SPECIFICALLY.
>> Tucker: ERODING CULTURE AS
OF THIS DEMOCRACY.
WE CAN ONLY GUESS AS TO WHAT
THAT MIGHT MEAN.
SPARTACUS DID ON EXPLAIN
HIMSELF.
BUT IF YOU WANTED TO UNDERMINE
DEMOCRACY, PROBABLY THE FIRST
THING YOU WOULD DO IS IGNORE THE
EXPRESSED WILL OF THE VOTERS.
INSTEAD, YOU CREATE SLIDESHOWS
TO WHAT THE ACTUAL POPULATION
WANTED.
OR, IF THE PRIORITIES THEY
EXPRESSED.
INSTEAD, YOU PRETEND THAT SOME
IRRELEVANT LETTER THAT BOB BARR
WROTE BACK IN MARCH IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN ALL OF IT, MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THE OPIOID CRISIS
WHERE THE ONGOING INVASION FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA FOR OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THEN, YOU WANT MAZIE HIRONO BACK
ON TV AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
SCREAMING ABOUT A COVER-UP, AND
THAT WAY MAYBE NO ONE WOULD
NOTICE THAT THE ROADS WERE
CRUMBLING OR THE SUICIDE RATE
WAS RISING.
OR THAT YOU OR REASONS YOU COULD
NEVER EXPLAIN WERE INTENT ON
WASTING MORE MONEY AND MORE
LIVES IN SYRIA OR YEMEN OR
VENEZUELA.
YOU CONTINUE TO LIVE UP HATRED
IN THE POPULATION AND DIVISION
NEEDLESS TO SAY IT, SO YOU
EMPLOY SLOGANS LIKE WHITE
PRIVILEGE OR TOXIC MASCULINITY
TO MAKE PEOPLE REALLY HATE EACH
OTHER.
OVER TIME THE POPULATION WOULD
BE SO MESMERIZED AND AFRAID THEY